was the night before Christmas and all
through the house not a creature was
stirring not even a mouse
by the chimney with care in hopes that
Saint Nicholas soon would be there
I'm Santa Claus
it's different out there all those kids
turned into adults they stopped
believing and one was magic
so for the good of Christmas I'm
retiring wow I didn't even know you
could do that I think we'd see what the
rest of the world's like as normal
people I'm making a list of things I
want to do like meet a crossing guard
Saturday warned you this is what I look
like here it's it's Dad me
you know I have a funny Cheeto put cocoa
in instead of coffee put a little
peppermint in there if you have that
chop up some cookies and
um Sprinkles name for the order Santa
my job is hard enough
for the first time I'm going to spend
Christmas with my family
new Santa is destroying Christmas spirit
when the last of the light goes out it
could be the end of Christmas I retire
too soon
I hired the wrong guy
I've got to go back to the North Pole
helps her disappear those are
disappearing you should have led with
that we're going
[Music]
please
[Music]
Christmas is in trouble let's go now
we're getting somewhere oh